however everyone did have a nice Easter
that I meant that sincerely Andy how was
your Easter oh very successful and yours
it was nice the Easter Bunny hid a bunch
of eggs in our yard and my kids had a
great time hunting for him oh yeah we
had a hunt too and let's just say this
year I did not come back empty-handed
here look check out my new keychain yeah
oh my god now it's good luck for him
even not so much for the Easter Bunny
you know what I'm saying Annie did you
take the Easter Bunny's foot is that
what you did
no I earned it punting and guile and now
it's my good luck charm and a warning to
all future Easter bunnies out there you
do not with Andy for God's sake
terrible that's that's awful no you know
it's awful waking up at sunrise every
Easter Sunday to find out that some
giant rabbit has crapped out a bunch of
eggs all over your yard sometimes it
takes me hours to find them all and one
time I accidentally cracked open one of
the eggs you know what was on the inside
what delicious candy yes what kind of
sick weirdo hides candy inside his body
well I finally put a stop to all of that
like to see how fast he can hippity hop
without this trust me we won't be seeing
the Easter Bunny again
what do you want no way finders keepers
if you're so magical grow another one
Andy give the Easter Bunny his foot back
fine next time tell your friend sandy
better sleep with one eye open alright
Andy take it easy I'm just I'm just
curious curious what you think of our
Easter sketched Jesus oh thanks for
asking hey Conan hey Andy I gotta tell
you I found this sketch a little dark
for my taste the rabbit's foot was a fun
visual though Jesus is feeling generous
so I'll give it three-and-a-half halos
that's pretty good yeah would it be okay
if I just did a quick plug you want to
plug something sure anything you want
Jesus okay great thanks hey everyone if
you're headed out to the desert for
Coachella this weekend I'm doing a
pop-up Mass every other hour we've got
wine artisanal communion wafers a dunk
tank all courtesy of our sponsor
draftkings draftkings daily fantasy
sports for cash and if you're on social
be sure to use the hashtag pray cello
Jesus Christ
ladies and gentlemen Jesus Christ some
believe the Son of God
you